hello YouTube just lovers in my friends
this is grunge in here and today I'm
going to show you a trap exists and
should have Trump or skew attack now the
more order for the pseudo Trump or ski
attack we'll start with the d4 and black
responds with a D file and after Bishop
to g5 you can see the first merit of the
bishop that Bishop is spinning the e
pole now against the sudo Trump or ski
attack the most reliable and aggressive
system by the black start with the move
c6 now the idea behind the save six is
Queen wants to come to the B Square and
that's where it can hang up that the
weakest spot in the white can which is
the b2 now against this the general
theory goes like III and here now at
this point if the black plays Queen b6
then white can click pin to c1 and then
white can look forward for the c4 so
nowadays there are there is a modern
approach to the shooter from power ski
and that is to play Bishop to a5 now the
system known as a Baltic defense from
the black and the idea is very simple
black wants to put his bishop outside
the pawn chain and then it will close
the center with a e6 so we have a
structure like a flower defense where
the bishop it's outside the pawn chain
and against this the line usual line
goes like c4 and here our chest straps
comes into the picture now if black
things he can trick the white by playing
this move D cross C Phi then black comes
to the blender house because first sight
it looks like black has given up the
center but there is a cunning idea
behind it so for example as a usual line
white will take the pawn then now you
can see this diagonal is open with the
help of D cross e-file and there are
nasty tricks looming with the Queen
check and that we are about to see so
here black will continue with the bishop
takes b1 and after our rook takes B one
black thinks I can trick my opponent
with this check and indeed white loses a
piece right now so King has to go to f1
and then black will capture the bishop
and if you count the pieces right now
black is a piece off but believe it or
not and this is exactly white ones
because now I give you a few seconds can
you find amazing mu over here
okay the move is Queen to b3 now the
first point is it's attacking two
squares EPS evan and b7
now if the b7 pawn drops then that will
lead us to the fall of the rook so
that's why most obvious response of the
blank will be either b6 or the b5 so in
one of my game
my opponent play b6 and I capture the
pawn and he played King to d7 and I
regained my piece and hear my opponent
plays Queen to f5 now this game give
will give you a very good idea how to
handle these positions and what exactly
we are getting out of this trap so my
opponent play Queen to a5 attacking my
rope and here I played efore sacrificing
a pawn so now it's attacking his queen
so he captured the pole I put my rook to
e1 and now he played Queen to f4
and now after Bishop to e6 plus King to
c7 it's time for the assessment
look at the development of the white
pieces white has already queen and two
pieces are out in the game where black
has only active pieces Queen this tall
PCs are sitting behind
they are almost slipping and not only
that look at this Bishop and the rook
they will take ages to come out and we
are already winning by positionally
let's see how his games goes on so here
I play d5 opening up the lines for the
King and my opponent desperately wants
to close the line so he played c5 and
here after some thinking
I played b6 and after across d6 Bishop
to c5
attacking the rook the only move is
Knight to c6
but after Queen to be 5 twice attacking
the knight the only move left for the
black is night to d4 but after pin to e4
black has to forcefully move the rook
and in my game my opponent plays rook to
c7 but after Queen captures King to d8
and Bishop to f7 you can see my bishop
and the rope are eyeing up that eh
square and black is very hard-pressed to
stop that and at this point my opponent
resign so that is a 1q trap exist in the
sugar trump or skin eyes up till now I
have been many player including 2100
plus players so this trap is quite new
and we can look forward to finish your
opponent very very quickly
I hope you enjoy my video feel free to
come in and I'll meet you soon bye